and conor has tweeted out something can
you bring up connor's tweet uh chin
connor tweeted out something like
uh like he doesn't take him seriously
it's not happening you're you know
you're a toy dude what are you talking
about
the problem is is connor's not from that
cut of cloth that these young kids are
like jake paul logan paul remember jake
paul started off as a youtuber so
when you give them
an inch
on anything like you look at jake paul
and dana white dana white did a video
directed towards jake paul jake paul
goes oh you want to make videos
well i have my
master's degree in making sizzle videos
check this out i have a crew around me
at all times they can edit and put this
thing up in [ __ ] five minutes it's
gonna destroy any content you can put
out
so uh connor puts out uh do you have it
here
right now on his instagram uh go to your
email yeah oh yeah i can watch watch it
there now we'll be able to watch jake
paul's yes from video yeah but let's
watch uh what started with connor
because again you're they're playing a
different ga so
jake will win i don't care who you are
maybe another youtuber can hang with him
when it comes to connor dana whoever it
is
nobody's going to beat jake at what jake
does as far as marketing and creating a
narrative on youtube and social media
he's the best there is the best this is
that's all that's how he got his fame
and his money so when you step into that
pool you better be ready to go when he
says you're a nobody
a nobody that's what he said yeah
because j so jake paul said so he says
that jake paul cause jake paul was
saying hey there's gonna be a fight
between me and connor and now you can
just play jake so basically all he says
is your nobody it's not happening
and then this is jake paul's rebuttal
conor mcgregor just tweeted at me
because of this interview he has to get
active again you know who knows when
that's gonna happen these are his tweets
and here's my response connor connor
connor you're more active on twitter
than you are in the octagon stop taking
trenbolone and start taking fights
you're more actively cheating on your
way than you are in the octagon your
priorities are mixed up put down the
bottle and get back a fighting you
haven't want to fight in five [ __ ]
years and the last time you did was
against cowboy cerrone who hasn't won a
fight against anyone since fighting you
i'm a nobody you say in this tweet well
yeah you're right i'm just a [ __ ] kid
from ohio i really am a nobody but this
is where you fought your sixth fight
there's literally two people in the
crowd and this is where i'm gonna be
fighting my sixth flight madison square
garden the mecca of boxing august sixth
i know you'll be watching kiddo here's
another fun fact in your 18th fight you
made 150 thousand dollars in my fifth
fight i made 15 million you want to talk
about pay-per-view buys nate robinson
1.8 million ben askren 500 000. tyrone
woodley won 500 000 tyrone woodley 2. no
one even wanted to see that fight and we
got 200 000 pay-per-view buys in the
last five years you've had zero
pay-per-view buys because you don't
[ __ ] fight you have a lot to say
about me but i'm sharing millions of
dollars with underpaid fighters while
you're sharing hookers with dana white
i'm sorry connor i know your pr team is
trying to hide that video you shouldn't
have [ __ ] with me connor this is my
game there's a new king in town i'm
running [ __ ] now what's up connor what's
up what's up last year and i won
knockout of the year you were just
getting knocked out fix your calcium
deficiency stop breaking your bones and
let's get in the [ __ ] ring and make
200 million dollars no matter how you
slice it we're just not on the same
level i'm my own boss yeah you made 100
million dollars when you fought floyd
but dana took half of it so no matter
what you do or what you make cut that
[ __ ] in half we went net worth for net
worth i would [ __ ] on you connor put the
bottle down get off of twitter get back
in the ring and shut the [ __ ] up i'm
going to put you back on a leash [ __ ]
you connor conor mcgregor just
these kids have they have no there's
like everything's offline i hate all
that i hate it too like the reason i
hate it all is because connor has
nothing to prove to anybody that
[ __ ] did it and brought and did
everything and fought all comers well
that's why he's calling him out though
but jake is doing to get on her skin so
that it creates the hype but as far as
like conor sent a tweet and then i'm
telling you you give these young kids a
[ __ ] inch these content creators
where he comes from yeah like dana did
that shitty like dad
facetime video talking [ __ ] to jake
jake's at a party in costa rica drinking
just want his fight he's hanging out
and someone goes hey see what dana does
he watch he goes get the crew together
rips a [ __ ]
hot video about dana beyond cocaine and
all this crazy [ __ ] and fighter pay they
edit it they put in graphics it's up
five minutes later yeah so you just stop
and there's also you're dealing with a
machine somebody said that's all they do
yes it's like getting in the ring with a
black belt when you've never done any
[ __ ] you know like uh
i just i don't even like being that mean
i i like personally like that's my thing
with them they're the there's like the
rules of the game these young kids there
is no trying to [ __ ] with somebody's
home they're savages marriage yeah like
to go after somebody's wife and all this
stuff yeah but literally it's like it's
not my gloves are off with this kid so
you know if you're gonna go out for me i
just go oh dude that's like you know
there's no uh there's there there's
i just don't like it i don't like doing
that to anybody but what's interesting
about this everyone knows i love jake
paul also a huge connor fan what's
interesting about this is
it's interesting that jake's
kind of angle on this is to talk about
pay-per-view buys when connor is bona
fide
the number one pay-per-view draw of all
time in the ufc in combat sports is
involved in the biggest pay-per-view of
all time with him versus floyd so it's
like if he goes you know at 200 000 buys
on this i'd you know whatever 100 000
and connor's going dude i'll get 200 000
bucks if i play chess yeah like
it's
like analytically like financially if in
every numerical
comparison you want to make between jake
and connor i know he says i have more
money he doesn't have more money he
doesn't so
every as far as fighting goes
money goes
you're not going to be connor dude he's
the one guy he can't flex his money on
he won't beat he won't beat conor in a
fight i don't know i'm not even talking
about that much it's so far i'm not even
talking about that yeah i don't want to
break that down what i do think is going
to happen though is
you know it's just
dana and you know stan is piped down
like you're not going to beat him at the
video social media does jake want to box
connor or mma him
don't say mma him though either though
you know you sound like you're 90. i
will do you want to mma him well there's
that's why are they going to mma each
other
that's my new term i come up with my own
[ __ ] terminology don't you know i'm
an older huh you know no i'm not do you
come up do you think this is gonna be a
boxing thing or is he going to mm that's
a street talk mma him though yeah that's
street talk that's my new thing now are
you going to mma him are you going to
box him but b tell me this so if you
want to critique you know you don't like
that did you like when conor threw the
doll yet uh
[Music]
i did because he got michael you got
glass in michaels she has his eyes i
don't like that [ __ ] yeah but say
there's nobody got hurt nobody actually
here's what i liked about that there's a
difference oh you like that here's what
i like about it
connor i mean khabib slapped artem
artem calls connor connor goes this is
going to be great hype for a fight he
gets all his boys they get on a g7 they
go to [ __ ] in vegas and they matching
square they yeah and they they pretend
to fight like he he does a whole
theatrical thing throws the thing see
this is what i think i don't think he
meant to break the window that's why i
think you're about to create a spectacle
i think this is where you're off because
conor
i think the difference between him and
jake is and why
it's not that i'm okay with it i don't
like those crazy antics that he does
outside the octagon
but
to me this is more personal you're
talking about a world-class fighter and
khabib world-class fighter and conor and
it was personal yeah conor wasn't like
hey get the camera crew together edit
this thing together and blasted out he
was it he wasn't at all i think that was
a
smart publicity stunt though
well the ufc ran with it yeah but notice
no one from conor's team blasted that
out i don't think conor mcgregor because
it went bad i don't i think because he
didn't go bad i think yes but i think
that with the glass in the eye somebody
couldn't fight as a result it became a
thing where i was like oh [ __ ] i think
it got a hand but if he hadn't broken
the glass i think part of that was all a
calculated thing to raise he was always
trying to raise you know crazy i don't
think you need to see i think that's
where jake and he's not a good guy but
that's where jake and connor is
different i think connor it was it was
personal and he was in like oh let's do
this get clicks he's too famous so
here's i think connor it was personal
and he went there literally to [ __ ] him
up that was his connor as a fighters
fighter it was literally to go there and
cause havoc here's nothing he didn't do
it to sell tickets that's the difference
here's my thing also about like so also
playing a different game so jake is
going after uh
connor and he's making it personal
don't forget connor makes [ __ ] really
personal he told dustin poirier that his
wife was slipping into his dms he he
kept saying stuff about his wife he was
really bad about um
muslims yeah and all their father is
family so like connor's getting a taste
of his own medicine and if you're going
to call jake khabib's not going to do
that no jose aldo's not going to do that
dustin's not going to do that jake
jake is giving connor a taste of his own
medicine and personally i don't like any
of that like i don't i love trash talk i
just don't like winning it's personal
personal and insulting like really bad
like stuff like personally i think it's
i just don't like that [ __ ] i think it's
classless but yeah we feel better and
we're old heads but the younger
generation is i don't like it the
younger generation like that and i think
it's a problem like there's no
there's no the fight club rules don't
exist anymore like the inside baseball
rules where there's rules to the fight
game into baseball that are unspoken you
don't go after people's family yeah
wives girlfriends yeah even if a guy has
side pieces that's right you don't talk
about that and that's right that's how
it should be it's called decency it's
called there has to be some rules
exactly and so these kids lost the rules
because they're getting clicks yeah the
younger generation is wrong about that i
agree 100 yeah they're wrong about it
and that's where maybe older people come
in and go this is wrong i know it's
shiny and you're going to swallow it but
there's a hook on that and and but
showtime's not doing that showtime like
even showtime commented on his thing it
was like oh you know like
everybody just they know they're getting
clicks they know it's gonna equal
pay-per-views or you know it's gonna add
to their investment just so we know that
when you do things for money and only
money there's a there's a word for that
it's called being a [ __ ] so people have
the like so people always like have this
thing about hookers and
she's a prostitute you're you're a
prostitute too bro if you've done a job
just for money and i have you're a [ __ ]
i've been a whole and you can feel it
you're selling yourself i've been a
[ __ ] when you're doing a gig for money
like [ __ ] dude what am i doing that's
why it's never worth it never ever never
you marry somebody for money you marry
for your friends oh you're paying for it
you're somebody for influence paying for
it yeah it's all lies you're a [ __ ]